am I a good wingman or am I not oh gosh
it's better wow I'm legitimately one of
the best Wing men ever Mark's the words
Mark is the worst
Mark is a actual piece of can I tell the
story I gotta tell us we went down to do
a show in Philly Dove took a girl down
to Philly to go watch the show right
yeah the girls get a ride back to New
York with Mark never talk to double
check
what were you talking to this girl about
that made her decide that she never
needs to see me again what was the other
one oh yeah Dove brought a girl into the
studio yeah and then I assume she's like
about to get a job here and then I
talked to Dove and he's like yeah I
brought her here after a date and then
Mark has been talking to her for two
hours one-on-one he goes I just had to
leave and it's just so because you're a
great husband and you have no interest
in these women and you just still talk
to him and waste everyone's time what's
wrong with the guy that's chatting dude
but how do you find a way to talk
everybody out I'm friends with dub
friends bro that's all yeah